be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about rogue and trace the
development of our character from a
super villain to one of the most
powerful and popular members of the
x-men team and what I'm hoping is that
by the end of all this you'll have a
better understanding of her character as
well as have some measure of preparation
for our upcoming discussion about all
new Avengers with regards to the Civil
War to lead up so while Chris Claremont
had initially planned to introduce rogue
in issue number 25 of the Carol Danvers
Miss Marvel series because of
publication was abruptly canceled with
issue number 23 due to poor sales
Clemmie was forced to wait two more
years to debut the character which came
about in the pages of Avengers annual
number 10 in 1981 while the reasons for
Claremont's creation of rogue have not
been specifically explained Wrote fits
in perfectly with a long line of female
characters created by Claremont within
the ex been universally Kitty Pryde Emma
Frost Psylocke and Jubilee jumping
forward a bit to 2005 with rogue six
issue limited series while her
character's real name had remained
completely unrevealed for over 20 years
following the rise of her popularity and
with the release of the x-men film in
2000 ro was provided an origin of her
own detailing the complete events of her
backstory going by the name anamarie
with no last name having ever been given
in the comics rogue grew up in Caldecott
Mississippi where she was raised
predominantly by her father and aunt
Carrie a strict but dutiful caretaker
following her mother's untimely death as
rogue began to mature into a teenager as
she began to manifest her power to
absorb the memories and abilities of
anyone she came into contact with the
first occurrence taking place when she
kisses her boyfriend Cody Robbins during
which time she absorbs his life force
and renders him comatose following this
the experience left rogue traumatized as
she was faced with the reality that
she'd never be able to live a normal
life because of her mutant ability and
began the practice of completely
covering her skin so as not to endanger
those around her following the incident
with Cody Robbins the boy's father
gathers a mob and sets out for
annamarie's house while her father is
able to hold the mob off long enough for
Anna Marie to escape into the swamps of
Mississippi her journey leads her into a
woman named Raven dark home better known
as a shape-shifting mutant mystique
under her way mystique effectively
becomes an adoptive mother of sorts and
under her tutelage rube begins using her
powers to help further the cause of
Mystique's Brotherhood of Evil Mutants
leading to her first appearance in
Avengers annual number 10 opening up
with Spider Woman Jessica drew rescuing
a woman who had fallen off the Golden
Gate Bridge in San Francisco after
Jessica gets the woman to the hospital
one of the doctors reveals that the loan
appears to have almost no brain activity
with her mind
functioning at the level of a newborn
finding herself joined by lieutenant
Sabrina morale of the San Francisco
Police Department
Jessica Drew is informed that the woman
is not just any Jane Doe but is actually
Carol Danvers who's been missing for six
months unsure of what to do spider-woman
calls for help in the form of Professor
Charles Xavier who agrees to come to San
Francisco to examine miss Marvel
telepathically during his examination he
discovers the Carol Danvers memory and
conscious mind have been completely
erased and after digging further
Professor X is also able to identify
Carol Danvers attacker as a mysterious
woman named rogue from here we switch to
New York City where rogue has attacked
Captain America defeating him with
extreme ease this particular scuffle
provides us with the first instance of
rogues abilities on display through her
contact with Miss Marvel rogue has
absorbed both Carol Danvers memories and
her powers including super strength
speed and flight rogue also explains
that since she maintained contact with
Carol Danvers for an extended period of
time instead of gaining these abilities
to barrera Lee Rogues current power set
exists as part of her indefinitely the
throwing Captain America through one of
the windows of Avengers mansion
prompting the team to send out a
distress call to iron man mister reveals
that Tony Stark had been incapacitated
by mystique who gained entrance to his
laboratory by disguising herself as
Janet Van Dyne the wasp following this
mystique reveals that when the
Brotherhood previously existed as a
group of mutants led by Magneto and
fighting on behalf of mutant rights
albeit using vigilante tactics following
Magneto's previous defeat by the x-men
mystique had taken over the team with
rogue operating as our apprentice
switching back to Avengers mansion room
becomes involved in a scuffle with
Thor's spider-woman vision and Wonder
Manson and Williams where she succeeds
in absorbing Ford's powers and
dispensing with the rest of the team
for making her escape now following this
first appearance which function as a way
from mystique to display her new role in
the Marvel Universe and provide us as
the reader with a display of rogues
abilities within the larger universe
rogue made scattered appearances in some
of Marvel's less popular books including
the solo series of Dazzler and Ron the
space knife before returning to the
forefront an uncanny x-men number 170
centering on rogue levy mystique and
seeking out Charles Xavier the store
revealed that as a side effect of her
absorption of the memories of others
particularly Carol Danvers rogue has
been experiencing a great deal of
psychological stress including your
inability to separate the thoughts and
memories of others from her own and so
after performing a psych evaluation
honor Professor Xavier not only admits
rogue to a school for gifted youngsters
but also make sure a probationary member
of the x-men team a decision that
angered the existing team to the point
that storm and Nightcrawler threatened
to leave while their decision results in
staying with the x-men this comes by way
of Professor X arguing that turning away
rogues request for help would actually
go against the overall mission of the
group in addition to this because the
character of rogue also served as a way
to maintain the element of Carol Danvers
without the concern of readers
forgetting about her
the rogue Carol Danvers dichotomy served
as a central part of her character or
Claremont's initial foray into Roche
time on the x-men focus on her gaining
the team's trust in issues 173 and 179
the ongoing struggle for control of her
mind came to a head when the Carol
Danvers persona was awakened after rogue
here's a message on the answering
machine of Charles Xavier from Carroll's
former boyfriend Michael Rossi sensing
that Ross sees in trouble rug rushes to
the shield Helicarrier breach being held
prisoner rescues him and takes him to
the childhood home of Carol Danvers in
Massachusetts however when Wasi comes to
instead of viewing Carol Danvers he
instead hears Carol's voice coming from
rogue who explains that when she
absorbed Carol's powers and memories she
also absorbed the feelings that Carol
had for OSI to this end Rosi rebukes
rogues outpouring of emotion and leaves
an anger now after this encounter and
going into the future of a character
because fan reception was strong we got
in the idea of rogue and Danvers
fighting over a physical body
Claremont continued the theme in uncanny
x-men number 236 for the rogue having
suffered a sexual assault at the hands
the team of Genosha prison guards while
being held captive as a result the
trauma of this incident forces road to
retreat as far as she can within an own
subconscious and brings her psyche face
to face with the sake of Carol Danvers
convincing rogue to let her take control
and were to rescue Wolverine and escape
the prison while rogue is initially
afraid of Danvers not relinquishing
control of her body Road reluctantly
agrees after which she and will reign
were able to succeed in their escape
following these events lo continues to
house both their own personality and
that apparel Danvers in thinner on mind
and at one point Danvers psyche is so
firmly in control that she adopts them
his Marvel costume for this
transformation only took place for a
couple of issues due to fans hating the
idea an uncanny x-men issues 246 and 247
titled the day of other lights and the
light that failed during a battle with
master mold the original central matrix
created by Bolivar Trask the Carol
Danvers persona is knocked unconscious
allowing road to take back control of
her own body where the ensuing skirmish
would see rogue captured by master mode
in an attempt to distract the rest of
the x-men from their mission to destroy
him road was able to send the telepathic
messages to psylocke informing her and
the rest of the team to focus all of
their energy on master mold instead of
attempting to free her from his grasp
as a result rogue is seemingly killed
off when both she and master mold were
sent to this huge perilous now where
road would remain absent from the pages
of the excellent comics for over a year
while Claremont focus on introducing
gambit and providing a more complete
backstory for storm the heart
reappearance came in the pages of
uncanny x-men number 269 after being
spat out by the siege perilous at the
x-men's base in Australia now while I
haven't been able to find a definitive
source for this with the x-men the
animated series looming on the horizon
it would stand to reason that rogues
return was a combination about fan
feedback and the popularity of her
character resulting in her appearance as
part of the show as a result a clean
slate was issue with issue number 269
and that immediately upon her
reappearance
rogue learns from a television news
report that her adoptive mother mystique
has been killed by an unknown assassin
distraught rogue attempts to locate the
x-men and in the process realizes that
because the siege perilous operates to
provide new lives for those that pass
through it
not only as Carol Danvers been purged
from ROS mind but the powers of Danvers
have been completely removed
well the story would go on to Ciro
confronted by Carol Danvers mind which
had manifested as a wholly separate
entity leading to a four way into the
savage land and a rescue at the hands of
Magneto after taking up as Magneto's
unofficial love interest for time
brogues powers are restored by the
priestess eldane of the Sun people who
in turn was killed by magneto realizing
the truth of Magneto's heart and that
he's seen for all intents and purposes
to be beyond redemption
rogue eventually abandon the Savage Land
returning to the x-men team proper
during this time and leading up to the
launch of the animated series in October
of 1991 the x-men comics experienced a
major shake-up with a launch of x-men
vol 2 issue number one written by Chris
Claremont and drawn by Jim Lee published
alongside the uncanny x-men line both
uncanny and x-men vol 2 we store the
roster of the team's most popular
members ending the Louise Simonson era
of X Factor and bringing all the mutants
under one fold operating as two teams
spanning the course of the first three
issues within the comics themselves and
because of the immense size of the new
x-men team Cyclops suggested to
Professor Xavier that the team be split
into two units the blue team and the
Gold team and rogue its place on the
blue team under the command of Cyclops
alongside Wolverine gambit psylocke and
beast it was during this time that
Rhodes most well-known romantic
relationship began to take shape as she
and fellow x-man gambit began their
tumultuous relationship although it was
clear that Rogen gambit had strong
feelings for one another
the relationship faced its fair share of
challenges most notably the fact that
rogues mutant ability made physical
contact between herself and gambit
impossible where these themes and others
would be explored more fully in both the
x-men the animated series and the
subsequent story is it unfolded in the
comics to mirror the show's popularity
over the next few years
well remained on the x-man and a
relationship with gambit remained a
focal point of her narrative however
because the immediate and eventual
departures of Claremont and Gimli had
removed the one-two punch of the x-men
series regarding both art and writing
styles the work of Scott Lobdell and
others was considered a bit lackluster
and fluctuating and that Webb saw her
powers both increase and decrease at
various times as well as temporarily
lose them in their entirety during a
battle with Vargas
while this standard of bouncing around
would continue throughout the late 1990s
with the early 2000 scene joke asada
take over as editor-in-chief that's part
of his rework of the x-men franchise
during the x-men reload event vol 2 was
renamed to new x-men with writer Grant
Morrison being bought on board the
uncanny x-men line was continued and a
third title called extreme x-men was
launched with Chris Claremont returning
his writer while Claremont's time on the
title lasted four years with a series
garnering a lukewarm reception on the
whole it became clear to both fans and
critics alike that the 90s version of
rogue would never return with the
extreme x-men centering on a version of
the team that operated globally ROK's
time under storms leadership in the
title between 2001 and 2004 saw
rehashing of 90 story lines including
the search for Destiny's Diaries and the
return of Vargas as a result and going
into 2004 and 2006 respectively extreme
x-men was cancelled the plot threads
were rolled over in the uncanny x-men
and Mike Carey took over the writing
duties during Kerry's tenure on the book
rogues profile grows in a major way in
issue number 192 rogue is permitted by
Cyclops to select her own team as he and
Professor X took many of the x-men into
outer space during a battle with Vulcan
as part of the Ed Brubaker deadly
Genesis miniseries with Iceman
cannonball Sabretooth lady mastermind
Karina sharp andar and mystique becoming
part of the team after leading the group
to victory against the super villain
group known as a children of the vault
robe announces that her team will leave
the x-mansion after which rogues x-men
encountered the supervillain pandemic
who injects rode with a virus known as
strain 88 in the hopes of copying her
powers for himself to this end the
effect of the virus is that rogues
powers were amplified to such a degree
that she causes instant death to anyone
she touches following this an issue
number 199 welcomes orbs over 8 billion
psyches from the Shiar super weapon
known as a heck a tomb that housed the
psyches within her own mind
leading into the events of Messiah War
Messiah Complex and 12 lights because
these stories focus on the birth of Hope
Summers as the first mutant after the
House of M rogue was captured by mr.
Sinister's Marauders with the help of
mystique
who
gambits had been working for sinister
finding themselves successful in
temporarily acquiring hope summers prior
to cable taking her into the future
misty touches the face of Hope Summers
to the face of road and what word is
revived
she's also cured of the multiple psyches
within our own mind using the events as
a means to rework works powers with
x-men legacies serving as a continuation
of new x-men with a different name
writer Mike Carey established that
rogues powers had never matured to the
fullest potential due to mental walls
that were created each time she absorbs
someone else's powers as a result
Professor X destroys these walls and
rogue finds herself in full control of
her powers meaning she can decide
whether or not she wants to absorb
someone's memories psyche powers or life
force instead of it happening
automatically whatever she touches
someone following this and going into
more recent events after the events of
Avengers vs. x-men robas granted
Avengers status as she joins the
avengers unity squad a team made up of
Avengers and mutants and an attempt to
promote unity between the two groups and
repair the public perception of mutants
written by Rick Remender and taking
place in uncanny Avengers the threads of
Avengers vs. x-men continued on and they
woke Harvard a great deal of animosity
towards scroll at which who she blamed
for the House of M which led directly
into the events of Avengers vs. x-men
and the death of Charles Xavier
where the actions of rogue would see her
absorbing the powers of Wolverine going
into a berserker state and killing the
Scarlet Witch will the story tied into
the actions of the apocalypse twins and
a plan to frame the earth for their
murder of a celestial and a complicated
and somewhat confusing set of events
time travel was invoked by Kane the
conqueror bidding to rebel absorbing the
minds and powers of every Avengers and
x-men in existence in order to ward off
the retaliating celestial host and spare
the Earth's destruction and so following
these events and going into secret Wars
in truth rogue did not see much in the
way of expansion or intriguing
storytelling instead emphasis was placed
on the launch of the main Secret Wars
event itself and the elimination of
dangling paths Reds going into the
launch of all-new all-different marvel
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and in the
next video that we have we'll have a
discussion on the all-new all-different
Avengers and how that ties in to the
lead-up to Civil War 2 and I will catch
you guys later peace